alors c'est bien quand même honteux de
nous voir un pays qui meurt là et puis
pendant que il y a une autre pays à côté
qui travaille
à quelques centaines de mètres en
contrebas de la station d'Alpes d'Huez
et sous les regards indifférents de
skieur un petit village
son nom villa recula en dit plus qu'une
longue histoire le passé c'est le
souvenir d'une certaine prospérité et
pour l'ancien maire Monsieur chalvain le
présent se résume brièvement
vous le savez on vit faut pas dire qu'on
vit dans ce village là on me jette
on comptait plus de 200 habitants à la
fin du siècle dernier en 1971 on en
recense 17
d'accès très difficile dès les premières
neiges villa recula et mourant au centre
du village le petit café existe toujours
et si les tables sont bien entretenues
plus personne ne vient s'y asseoir
alors hier c'était dimanche vous avez
pas eu vous avez des clients
et c'est toujours comme ça c'est
toujours comme ça je reste des mois à
savoir un client
et puis les il est retraité alors on est
avec sa petite retraite en vigueur ça
représente une charge ce café quand même
bien sûr ça représente une charge mais
on a toujours tenu à cause que mon mari
il a des enfants et on a une grande
licence alors à cause de grandes
distances on tient pour nos enfants
et ça vous coûte cher
et si on vous disait demain il faut
quitter le village
si on me disait de ma volonté moi je
dirais que je le quitte pas je reste là
tant pis je fermerai mon café mais je
reste là
on ne voit plus de jeunes Villard recula
il y a quelques années devant
l'insuffisance du nombre des élèves ont
décidé de fermer les colles pour ceux
qui restèrent l'absence d'une route
praticable en hiver posa de nombreux
problèmes
[Musique]
la route était jamais ouverte et que les
enfants étaient obligés d'aller au
téléski de Villard de prendre le signal
de descendre sur les sur les télésièges
pour prendre le coeur halal et
d'éteindre au bout en ce moment ils
allaient au bout alors c'est pas
toujours possible quand il fait mauvais
au pire
alors il reste là puis après l'école
nous envoie un mot il y a trop d'absence
il se rend pas compte
mais enfin ils en ont plus ils ont eu
des fois les mains
traverser tous les gars qui restaient au
village par là c'est l'armée qui dit
traverser parce que
ça perdu il se mange froid quoi
alors pour aller à l'école
je me rappelle
quant au vivre ils sont acheminés
bénévolement par des CRS de haute
montagne
[Musique]
ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces conditions de vie déjà dur sont
aggravés lorsque les éléments se
déchaînent les tempêtes de haute
montagne n'ont rien à envier aux
tempêtes de l'océan si à la tempête il
n'y a rien qui existe rien rien même pas
le téléphone quelquefois oui puisqu'on a
un peu de radio en liaison avec la
gendarmerie
c'est pour ça on n'a pas le droit d'être
malade on n'a pas le droit de se blesser
si une tempête c'est interdit pourtant
je suis à quelques minutes d'une station
et du XXe siècle ou du 21e bientôt et
qui a tous les moyens pour se défendre
[Musique]
alors c'est bien quand même honteux de
nous voir un pays qui meurt et puis
pendant que il y a une autre pays à côté
qui travaille c'est pas juste il est
valable ce village puisqu'il y a déjà un
domaine skiable donc il est valable bien
sûr
donc vous préconisez que ce soit les
habitants et même qu'il sauve
parfaitement mon village m'en est même
pas satellite de l'Alpe d'Huez village à
part entière qui demande à se développer
tout seul voilà
se défendre oui la mort du village n'est
pas inéluctable et nous verrons que
villa recula ne manque pas d'un tout
pour prendre son avenir en main
[Musique]